when i lived in thailand there were like
so many things that i didn't like about
liverpool but this thing i [ __ ]
there's things i [ __ ] love as well so
it's
it's all like a give and take wherever
you live like the more it's funny right
because when i
when i was a kid i was like i want to
live in here i want to live an ex it'd
be cool if i lived there but like the
more i
move around and the more i travel the
less i know where i want to settle down
yeah because because like the more i
travel the more i'm like man i really
love this one thing about that one place
but man i
really hate that one thing about that
one really wants me to
like i don't know like this covert
situation has just made me feel
trapped in this country for sure this
has probably been like one of the
longest
i've gone through in my entire life
without
without flying somewhere yeah yeah i
mean yeah i don't know
like for me as well like this is the
longest i've been in japan for like an
extended period of time without going
anywhere
and i've definitely i don't know i
haven't noticed anything new
about or knew about you know like any of
the good parts about living here or any
of that bad parts but yeah
i don't know it's it's made me
appreciate the things that i really like
yeah and [ __ ] despise the things that
i hate
it's like to another level yeah yeah i
wake up every day and i walk past my
router and i just smile
like damn damn i have a gigabyte
download and upload that's just
beautiful
i'd love to see it dude i don't know why
i heard you say naruto
i just i just sit by and i'm like damn
you're good damn
damn you do your job good yeah
don't talk to me until you have until
you've experienced the point for
uploading no dude because
in in [ __ ] wales man you would get
like yeah but you live in the middle of
[ __ ] no yeah right so you would
they'd be like oh yeah we only have
copper wire by the way um we're not
gonna put near the wire down uh here's
your 0.1
download that doesn't work half the time
and it's like cool
and then they charge you like [ __ ]
eighty dollars a month for it it's like
okay
why it doesn't work that's what it was
like for us in australia as well we had
a couple wires everywhere yeah and then
they say that like oh someone will come
on this day and then no one [ __ ]
turns up
that happens so many times or they turn
up they'd be like yeah they're gonna
we're gonna send someone to fix it
they turn up and they're like yeah i
have no idea what's wrong with it like a
straight like especially in australia
the the
whole if i were to sum up the whole like
just service business
side of things in one phrase it would
just be well that was a [ __ ] lie
like the service may never show up on
time transport never [ __ ] shows up on
time
yeah like oh my god the australian the
sydney sydney transport
i don't know about other parts of
australia but sydney transport was had
to be one of the worst i've ever
experienced right now like really
if you go okay so i had to catch a bus
every day to go to youtube right yeah
and this bus turns up every 20 minutes
that's what it says
on the timetable at the state at the
stop right so i'm like okay cool this
next one's coming in 10 minutes
yeah 10 minutes passes no bus like not a
single boss i'm like did i miss it while
i was looking down on my phone where is
it
right whatever another 10 minutes
doesn't show up yeah yeah
okay but then five minutes before the
next bus shows up
yeah the previous bus shows up right
right but because the bus is full
it doesn't stop yeah so i'm like not
only are you 15 minutes late
but this [ __ ] didn't even stop
for me
you [ __ ] have that in like wales as
well this boy's lucky he grew up in a
city
yeah but like i mean i did too
technically oh [ __ ]
he drew up in sydney
which is like the biggest one of the
biggest city in australia
like my bus there was the one that i
used to uh
if i wanted to go to england like
chester i would have to get this bus and
it was every
30 minutes problem was is that it was
always give or take 30 minutes late
like 30 minutes late or early so the
whole you basically just had to just go
there and wait
and like if it said like you know half
three it would just turn up at four
yeah and then you were like is this the
next bus that's early or is it
this bus that it's late i don't know
it's basically [ __ ]
yeah it was it was it was bad as well
because not only did sometimes the bus
was late but
sometimes the bus would come five
minutes early because i don't know it
just
yes like it wasn't really a schedule it
was just like a rough
estimate it's like a recommended route
you should probably get here
recommended time of arrival don't stick
around
though you know [ __ ] those kids uh yeah
and it's the same with like de uh
package deliveries in in the uk i hated
it because they would say
you know between eight eight am and
eight pm you give your house and it's
like
well so i just got to be at the house
the whole [ __ ] hours could you
just say tuesday yeah like that is eight
to eight you know what i mean
and then it wouldn't even turn up on the
day sometimes so it's like what is it
meanwhile meanwhile here in japan we
just got a couch for the office
just this morning right and we set it
for 12 p.m to 2 p.m yeah
2-hour window perfect yeah the couch
arrives at 1201
yeah yeah and they phone you as well
they phone you they show you to make
sure that
you're in and you're like they can come
and everything and it's it's beautiful
and if you miss it you can also just
rest say if you miss it like 8 a.m
you can reschedule it the same day for
it to come out like 4 p.m yeah which is
like insane's in the uk if you miss it
it's like
right well next month we have a schedule
uh we have a slot 3 and it's like what
it was horrible pre-ordering games and
the games will turn up like four days
late and then you might miss it and they
wouldn't post it through the letterbox
so you got to call them up or go online
and then be like oh we have a free slot
in
five days it's like five days i
pre-ordered this game
we made five days see because back when
i was living in australia i know i got a
lot of comments about this but
we have amazon now in australia but back
when i was living in australia
congratulations
yeah i know we finally got it because
people are like joey what are you
talking about we do have amazon
back when i was living in australia we
didn't have amazon all right back up
back in my
days we didn't have amazon i don't know
why joey's an australian boomer now i'm
an australian boomer
back in my day we didn't have amazon yet
like amazon's only
like a recent thing that got introduced
to australia because we only had ebay
yeah wow why would you use ebay for
anything
yeah like i i still have never
experienced amazon now or the comforts
of
like living in a place where you can
just get your package literally hours
after oh yeah [ __ ] beautiful
order i mean especially coming from me
who've never experienced amazon until
moving to japan the moment
the first week of me experiencing amazon
i was like i'm i feel like a god like i
can
just get things delivered now without
having to wait
arduous amounts of time yeah i don't
know how people moved to japan before
amazon existed
as like a gaijin oh my god i don't know
i i don't know
i guess my house just wouldn't be
furnished for like a month i guess or
even more
and [ __ ] knows how i would just get like
normal necessities that i just
can't find and can't find it yeah right
it's like oh you know i need a i need a
phone charger i could just you know go
on amazon get it delivered probably the
same day or i could trek
30 minutes by train to the closest big
camera to buy one measly cable
like why would i do that tokyo doesn't
have this but london did london had uh
amazon
now and it was basically like two hour
windows yeah you could if you ordered it
it would come in two hours
oh wow yeah it was it was pretty good i
was insane like that
shipping yeah like some sometimes we
would be at a house party
and we'd run out of alcohol and like
instead of going to the tescos we'd
literally just order our alcohol off
amazon
yeah and it would just turn up like an
hour later when we were like low on
beers yeah yeah
this is the future that's this is this
like a whole crate and then also like i
remember i ordered the crate of beer and
like a nintendo switch game and i was
like sick
so i was like who ordered this
yeah he was at a party and they were
like who ordered [ __ ] mario party
super
sorry super mario party and i'm like no
that's me yeah it was at the bottom of
your house
i just really wanted to play mario party
i'm really [ __ ] jealous of the guy in
the other person
i really wanted him that's awesome
though i think it would i think on their
internet it was quicker to get it
delivered on amazon now than you want to
download it
and like wow that's because it downloads
user [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah true that's like first
world problems in a nutshell
download too slow just order it off
it's slightly faster
because when i used to make uh long
videos i had to
leave my pc on all night and a bit on
the next day and i could
use it because if this is just upload
files for evan to edit
um i would have to leave it on all night
hoping that when i woke up they were all
uploaded otherwise i probably wouldn't
be able to use my pc
right so yeah that was a pain in the ass
now i just uploaded one hour because
that's
that's wrong with the copper wiring
right is that like when you're using
an upload for example like really
heavily the download
has to compensate for the upload so
yeah so like every time i would like
upload a video at like 1am right i
couldn't use the internet because i had
legitimately like [ __ ] dial up speech
i was like you're going back to dial-up
yeah
it was legitimately dial-up speed like i
could it took like two minutes to load
up twitter
yeah and i'm just like i can't i can't i
can't do this i can't live like that i
can't do this man why would you do this
to me
yeah it's crazy and they said like the
companies used to throttle my internet
all the [ __ ] time
god were you with virgin yeah [ __ ]
virgin man
media [ __ ] sucks my god what a
version company
they think you're really worried about
companies because like they were they
they on paper they give you the best
internet speech downloads yeah never
[ __ ] saw it once
you never see it and at peak times man
you are
you are not getting anywhere close near
to what they advertise to you yeah the
moment you
upload or download anything as well they
immediately throttle you and i had to
call them up so many times
like hey hey turn that [ __ ] off i paid
for this
and they charge you so much we're going
back to the days of dialogue where you
have to be
like mom get off the phone are you
downloading a game
my little brother when i used to play
league at home i'd be like my ping would
go from like maybe 60
60 yeah 150 like i remember oh and get
off the [ __ ]
pornhub cohen like whenever
i remember back in university whenever
you were living in like a shared house
my god trying to game in a shared house
is [ __ ] impossible
because yeah your ping would just your
ping would either be like
10 when no one's awake or when did it
when it's dinner time it's like [ __ ]
800.
i'm like who's [ __ ] downloading
another episode of game of thrones and
everyone's a [ __ ] doubt
everyone's torrentially everyone puts
their hands up
no that was i mean it was [ __ ] worse
for me because because like when i was
doing
youtube like back in australia all of my
youtuber friends were in america right
so every time i jump onto like gmod or
something on a good day my ping would be
like 300.
i'll be like guys why even play at 300
percent
because i was desperate for friends
i didn't have any i didn't have any
youtuber friends in australia there must
be a formula for like
ping uh correlation with how desperate
you are to hang out with that person
because i play league of legends a lot
with dyson emily and it's like 200 ping
and i'm like
man this sucks but it's really fun exam
i wouldn't oh yeah no i mean 300 ping
gmod was still fun
yeah but i mean yeah no one could kill
me because i just keep [ __ ]
teleport the lag compensation what what
is the value of friendship
right is it 300 what is your penguin we
should break down the value of
friendship by ping number
it's like would i pay 160 ping for you
yeah
i'll i'll pay you that 800 ping ultimate
friend
100 points justin i just want to talk to
you man
that's all i want